hello everyone welcome to today's
broadcast the clinical utility of 125
dihydroxy vitamin d i am christina
mahalik of labyrinth and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lovers and
sponsored by SIA Saran the asuras
incorporated offers the broadest fully
automated infectious disease and
specially Diagnostics menu including
best-in-class vitamin D these quality
assays are analyzed on the versatile
liaison excel platform with their
excellent instruments in assays the
asuras
value through sales service and support
solutions to clinical laboratories by
consolidating their menu in order to
streamline processes and increase
efficiency for more information please
visit the asuras comm we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button and the lower
left of the presentation window will
answer as many questions as time permits
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button located at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
the window this is an educational
webinar and offers free continuing
education credits for viewing after the
webinar is over please click on the C e
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process for obtaining your credit it is
now my pleasure to introduce today's
speaker dr. Gregory plotnikov dr.
Gregory plotnikov is a board certified
intern
and pediatrician who has received
national and international honors for
his work in cross-cultural in
integrative medicine before opening
Minnesota personalized medicine dr.
plotnikov served as an integrative
medicine physician as the penne George
Institute for Health and healing and as
a senior consultant at the Center for
healthcare innovation u lino healthcare
in Minneapolis Minnesota
dr. plotnikov is a graduate of Carleton
College Harvard Divinity School in the
University of Minnesota Medical School
dr. plotnikov is a frequent invited
speaker and has been quoted in numerous
national magazines including the New
York Times Chicago Tribune and los
angeles time he has been heard on
multiple radio programs including All
Things Considered speaking of faith and
science Friday since 2003 article on
vitamin C in chronic pain is one of the
most highly cited art cited articles in
the history of the Mayo Clinic
proceedings I will now turn the
presentation over to dr. Platt McCobb
for his presentation great well thank
you Christina thank you our room for
joining us today this is actually a very
important topic and article of testing
that isn't well understood often so I
want today to be clinically meaningful
both for clinicians as well as for
people supporting clinicians in
laboratory settings and this test to the
125 dihydroxy vitamin D is actually
measurement of the actual sequel steroid
that you see below you a couple quick
things that just start out first but
we'll advance supplies here first I work
at mints I'd link sort of personalized
medicine I'm an active clinician with a
long waiting list of persons for persons
who
I've been through a lot medical
evaluation and still don't have a
diagnosis or have a diagnosis but no
treatment plan is effecting positive
change it's a very unique practice
tertiary quaternary I'm a fifth opinion
type of clinic and I need to let you
know I'm not going to discuss any
off-label use or any investigational
applications and I do it one financial
relationship to disclose
does die sword is a providing an
honorarium for me to present this
presentation for you today
so that's started we're going to talk
about vitamin D and when you think of
lemon D we think about sun exposure we
think about all the every photon
touching our skin breaking open that
steroid and starting as I'm in the
initiation process but there's been a
lot of concern about vitamin D and
there's a lot of debate as whether we
should test for it but it's just simple
then toward whether should even be
outside in the Sun every day to close
the chairman of one world famous clinic
he said every photon taking our skin is
a potential carcinogen well there might
be over calling it a bit but I wanted to
start by just kind of beautiful images
around the topic that actually is deeply
meaningful behind the scenes so how we
going to do this here's the flow for
today's presentation we're going to talk
about case studies and hypercalcemia
hypocalcemia nomal Kelsey Mia cases were
and make sense to test with a 125
dihydroxy vitamin d and we're going to
talk about monitoring treatments
including on some additional nuances of
where this test can be very very helpful
we've got nine case studies to go
through seven of them are core
hypercalcemia so let's start out with
very beginning first as you may recall
is that vitamin D is actually produced
in our skin from the Sun we started with
a pre pre vitamin D
70 hydro cholesterol which then with sun
exposure and that's offered by the be
light of a certain strength can reach a
certain level of our skin pop open the
second ring and you have production of
cholecalciferol this one goes into the
liver where it can then be and go
through its first activation producing
kelsa dial basically this yes we never
produce kalsa dial and can go with
hasn't understood is that it goes to the
kidney in proximal tubule one of
hydroxylase will then produce the
dihydroxy lemon d which is so important
for calcium and phosphorus homeostasis
however there's a lot more to the story
so the right-hand side of the screen
here you see the nuances which are now
coming forth one is vitamin D receptors
seem to be playing a cigarrette role in
health and well-being still being worked
out but polymorphisms sniff in these
these variations appear to possibly play
a role in health and disease second
concern are they sipped the p450 enzymes
the 2781 the 20mb one the 24k one which
is sometimes called the two are one
these are all very important how vitamin
D is made and broken down and then
there's also a vitamin D binding protein
about 99% of vitamin D is ikey bound
only 1% is actually active variations in
binding protein variations and albumin
can defective variations in free vitamin
D potentially not established with these
are hypotheses which are now being
examined key points let's um kind of
start off with the key points first the
125 dihydroxy vitamin D is the activated
form this is what binds to the vitamin d
receptor which is part of the soup
family of nuclear receptors and this is
what makes vitamin D a hormone rather
than a vitamin
we call that vitamins and minerals or
cofactors and enzymatic reactions
vitamin D is @je hormone is actually
binds to receptor and affects gene
expression in fact the gene expression
of perhaps 2,000 key genes or body and
certain genes are keenly important for
mood memory energy sleep generalized
oomph power but in particular we know
that their vitamin D scent receptors
throughout the brain for cognitive and
emotional parts are removable marrow
cell array skeletal muscle cell these
are all covered with vitamin D receptors
remedies clearly playing a role they're
infecting genomic expression so why not
measure 125 dihydroxy vitamin d and
everyone well the point is it's not the
best measure for vitamin d the measure
for vitamin D status is the 25 hydroxy
vitamin D and this is really a critical
and critically important point people on
these electronic medical records
accidentally press the want wrong button
and get the wrong result that's not what
they need for vitamin D status is 25
hydroxy vitamin D a 125 is not helpful
for assessing vitamin D status what we
will see today in through 9 plus case
studies is where it is critical and
critically important for for diagnostic
and therapeutic purposes but for the
best majority of tests of vitamin D
where you want to actually know vitamin
D status you want to get the 25 hydroxy
vitamin D no the 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
has a circulating half-life that is
relatively short and there is a diurnal
variation like with many other hormones
and so in fact for anti research studies
or any kind of consistency where there's
repeated measure
you're going to want to have two done
about approximately the same time kinda
third to a critical point is that the
concentration of the 125 dihydroxy
vitamin d is a thousand times less than
that of the 25 hydroxy d wow that means
that testing for this has to be
exquisitely sensitive and to get
accurate reproducible measures you want
to have a really good product and notice
that the reference ranges between about
15 and 75 micrograms per ml as opposed
to the 25 hydroxy D which generally runs
in nanograms per ml now reviewing again
where we're going with this it's kind of
the 1700 d hydro cholesterol the
president's ultraviolet B a goes to
pre-banton D which then goes to
cholecalciferol but in d3 or herbal
kalsa four' o vitamin d2 now this is
really important there's a lot of people
ask oh I'm taking vitamin D and most
vitamin D in the stores is I'm in d3
cholecalciferol which is ultraviolet be
activated lanlan from sheep from the
cheap wool
ergo Calcifer all which is live in d2 is
ultraviolet be activated and transformed
her go Cal several found in fungal cell
walls and this is going to come from
mushrooms so yes some activate mushrooms
will be a good source of vitamin d2
which can be active but looks a much
shorter half-life and vitamin d3 now
notice that assignment d3 which is by
oral means or by sun exposure means has
to go through r1 to become kelsa dial
that is what takes place in the liver
kalsa dial then would be a replenishment
in liver failure perhaps
and then 20-some b1 will gun create the
ff8 form of vitamin D the 125 also known
as calcitriol and note that there are a
number of prescription drugs listed here
Herbal Calcifer all kelsa dial
calcitriol these are all available on
prescriptions all right so in this we
will come back to this picture again and
again I just want to show you that the
125 which is that near the bottom middle
of the circle is a negative regulator of
parathyroid hormone and a positive
regulator of fgf 23 the fibrinogen
growth factor these in turn have either
positive or negative regulation in
Section 27b 1 and so therefore there is
a lot of exquisite homeostatic
monitoring and balancing of the system
including the kind of breakdown of
vitamin D we'll come back to that but
this would not be important but just
know that it's kind of home instead of
control of 125 dihydroxy vitamin d means
that that you should have a consistency
at the same time of the day day by day
for measurements in activity ok so what
are some other clinical pearls that need
to know one is that in severe vitamin D
deficiency 25 hydroxy vitamin D the 125
can go really low because there's just
not enough stuff around for it to work
on second thing is that the 125 can also
be low where it can be normal with
severe the really high levels of the 25
hydroxy vitamin D and third is that you
would expect the 125 levels to go low as
you have more severe degrees of renal
impairment that is the
mayor filtration rate drops syllable the
125 dihydroxy vitamin d and that's why
it can be so important to measure on
people or on renal dialysis or
approaching dialysis in fact calcitriol
supplementation is now considered the
standard of care in dialysis patients
because of its importance as a hormone
operating throughout the body
now another thing is there been lot
people been measuring 125 dihydroxy
vitamin D for a lot of different reasons
outside of kind of established
understood frameworks of hypercalcemia
and the like and so it's important to
recognize that actually you can get high
levels potentially of 125 with low
levels of the 25 and the reasoning is
this low 25 means low ionized calcium
low and as calcium means increase
parathyroid hormone to maintain calcium
levels increased parathyroid hormone
means increased 125 D hydroxy vitamin D
and so this is something that is a
nuance and can actually help an
interpretation of data by putting it
into a context so there could be reasons
for getting both the 25 and the 125 at
the same time no but most cases if you
see a low 125 and a low PTH in a setting
of a Cal hypercalcemia then it rules out
the two most common causes PTH and the
125 high dihydroxy as being the causal
[Music]
trigger a driver of the hypercalcemia
finding then really important for
analysis so context is most times we
want to take a look at the 125s in the
case of hypercalcemia
so let's set this is kind of a a
familiar situation here we have a 58
year old coming to the emergency room
they've got a week of confusion
disorientation polyuria polydipsia
differential diagnosis is quite broad to
see of diabetes severe what is going on
here this can keep tachycardic is that
ultra mental altered mental says he was
dehydration in this case instead of
having high blood sugars he's got a high
white count he's got a high platelet
count and his calcium level is sky-high
off the roof okay it's not diabetes what
is it well in this case then you're
thinking about okay what are the causes
for hypercalcemia and that's why I
really want you to know about the
differential diagnosis what you need to
be thinking what you think good then you
know exactly what are the tests that you
need to order and so for inpatient
hypercalcemia it's included ER visits we
have to think living themed legacy
malignancy so a person like this you
want to get a past medical history
becomes very important but the
differential diagnosis can include
unrecognized multiply myeloma from
before you can have a primary
hyperparathyroidism you can have
elevated parathyroid hormone-related
protein and so that is again a byproduct
of cancer and so it would be considered
a paraneoplastic phenomenon you kind of
excessive supplementation of vitamin D
and you know how many people have seen
people doing way too much vitamin D
thinking that more is better and it's
possible and again one excessive 125
production and that can include okay
non-solid malignancies such as lymphomas
think about a post transplant and the
like look include a very granulomatous
disease
including sarcoid the outpatient
hypocalcemia though primarily have to
think about hyperparathyroidism primary
you can have now cases of
hyperthyroidism ma hypercalcemia the
vitamin d attacks occasion of course the
granulomatous diseases malignancies
acromegaly growth hormone variety of
other things that relate to medications
or VIP Ouma's or more rare things that's
majority need to grow out these before
going to the more more esoteric areas so
how does this all play out let's do a
case study okay here's a 67 year-old
previously healthy guy it comes in with
again polyuria honking gait dizziness
confusion message or such people are
going to see are going to be diabetic
but in fact it could be a diabetic but
it's blood sugars are doing okay even
acute renal failure though his crap
nina's up to 4.9 his GFR is quite low
nineties got this calcium at sixteen
point three key point hyper calcium
levels main hypercalcemia main hyper to
me they mean polyuria so a frequent
cause of frequent urination
if parathyroid hormones just slightly
high so give it IV fluid calcitonin to
madryn eight alpha song shows the right
- period parathyroid mass you think ah
okay a mom we've got the answer area
it's got a primary hyperparathyroidism
so the guns and get the parathyroid
receptive PTH drops from a slightly high
level to a very normal level and
crannium normalizes great then PTH
remains low and so we've got successful
resolution of primary
hyperparathyroidism yay but the calcium
remain
hi what do you do now how can you sling
that's when we need to think okay what's
the differential diagnosis for this this
is a perioperative phenomenon or is
there something else underlying this
remember that the parathyroid hormone
level was not all that high and that
parathyroid mass may have explained it
but it has not solved the initial
problem so we need to think about our
differential diagnosis okay we want to
address primary hyperparathyroidism so
if you have hyperthyroidism Lizzie get
vitamin D intoxicated is you have a
paraneoplastic process have great
moments granulomatous disease malignancy
acromegaly something else this will work
through so malignancy the parathyroid
hormone-related protein is normal the
125 comes back sky-high okay actually so
we have a new issue here you've got a
very high 125 dihydroxy worse is coming
from the differential diagnosis for this
so according to granulomas to
granulomatous disease will even see
either a solid organ or lymphoma a
hormonal issue growth hormone thyroid or
something beyond this so how do we value
value 8 this so assessing for
granulomatous disease assessing for bone
Mets consider this will come back to the
very end of the program called
evaluation of potential bone Maps no
signs of growth hormone excess got to
look for malignancy so and that's part
of where the differential diagnosis
comes in so so she were missing some
slides here so okay well the case is is
that an Tia end up getting a PET scan
you got skin for his spleen lit up and
diagnosis was he actually had a large
b-cell lymphoma and spleen that produced
the one
i hydroxylase and so recall one alpha
hydroxylase which is the activating
enzyme found primarily in the kidney
obsession can become throughout the body
and so therefore it was in if this was
unrestricted of production and
uncontrolled production of the 125
dihydroxy vitamin d so in cases then i
know when splenectomy and everything
normalized okay so that was the first
such case okay okay broad differential
we can narrow it down they used in 125
testing was really important there for
them really focusing on where we're
going to find and why we need to pursue
doing a PET scan study
so if next case is a 65 year old keep
vitamin D deficient so if they're going
high-dose
kirgo Calcifer all available
over-the-counter sold as vitamin D to me
her go Peltzer for all is a prescription
drug
generally 50,000 their national units
once or twice a week you've done that
for three months and he becomes
symptomatic aha
and getting too much his calcium is
fourteen point one yes he's going to be
symptomatic with that including polyuria
and mental status changes like how we
can work this up well we know the first
seven cases of presenter about
hypercalcemia so here it is a
hypercalcemia case how we can work this
up again the differential diagnosis
hyperparathyroidism vitamin d
intoxication granulomatous disease
malignancies acromegaly being the top of
the list so and this is the ordering
that we would do we add maybe a TF
nation here as well depending on what
else you would be finding notice that
the 125 is that is after a series of
tests maybe an organ is all at the same
time to pay on clinical situation so
pth came back normal 20 vitamin D came
back normal so it's not an intoxication
issue his parathyroid hormone-related
protein came back to normal and is 125
is elevated okay now we have to think
about why is this going to be the case
so let's go hunting for malignancies
Ches x-ray CT or negative aces
suggestive and that's the NGO temps and
converting enzyme tests which can be
elevated in sarcoid but what next here
so treat him with prednisone for a
presumptive sarcoid and he gets better
125 normalizes but it goes back up at
the prednisone has stopped and okay
here's our case existing library with a
PET CT we had intense clinic uptake with
this the underwent splenectomy so
similar to the case before and in this
case they'll it's not a malignancy like
the large b-cell lymphoma that we saw in
explained in this case it is sarcoid in
the spleen and so it removes penectomy
things will resolve so all sorts of
stuff here at times half way through is
that yes treatment prison print ISM
presumptively things normalized but you
monitor the 125 and you can get a
recurrence after the prednisone is
discontinued because you're monitoring
and you don't want someone in prednisone
all the time you know there's too many
downside steps so that's when you go
hunting we find the malignant AVM
sarcoid zit or the granulomatous disease
and that's great your address so these
are two common cases third this next
case chronic kidney disease and stage
renal disease is again it's another time
we're going to see that a lot here's an
81 year old gentleman he's got
crying renal failure due to diabetes
isn't on dialysis for six years we've
had progressive hypercalcemia so with
that then you're going to discontinue
the prescription calcitriol thinking
that you're paying too much and but
because fatigue he's got anorexia
Sunday's is examines normal it's got
normal routine labs what now so we had
to go back to again primary or in this
case tertiary hyperparathyroidism by the
D intoxication increased 125 from
granulomas C's Milligan C acromegaly
yes I want you to really know the
difference or diagnosis the end of the
presentation let's go through it
parathyroid hormones normal vitamin D is
normal it is related protein is normal
the 125 is high end of normal but normal
Geoff x-rays normal is
angiotensin-converting enzyme is at a
level is borderline what now what's it
what's going to explain this progressive
hypercalcemia and what's the most cost
effective route to evaluating it well
basically laboratory results to the
calcium and the 125 dihydroxy vitamin d
test we've got to consider sarcoid
granulomas granulomatous disease like TB
or histo lymphoma other malignancies
growth hormone excess and this is why a
conventional is so important Nelson
level 55 within the normal range but
what is the range of variation among
this so you don't want something that's
going to be wildly inaccurate this is
the time where you really are going to
want to have
rigor and have to get an accurate
measurement here
so because you know we can spend to
$5,000 in PET scan we can do all kind
just we can do a variety of things which
are invasive expensive you might not get
the answer in this case the clinical
suspicion was such that we need to do a
skin biopsy and so it's a non kkn
granuloma a nun multinucleated giant
cells okay we've got another case of
granulomatous related disease-causing
hypercalcemia that can be addressed okay
and we're treated prednisone and what's
a question and so can our time mantra
symptoms does exam that calcium levels
have been careful about muse of vitamin
D itself and then kind of monitor the
125 getting good reason why measuring at
the same time of the day and using you
know superb superbly rigorous testing
capacity is going to give you excellent
clinical guidance in this so in case so
he was able go 16 months without
prednisone and with monitoring and so
it's kind of a case against zero
monitoring can be so helpful all right
how about dogs ever affect women of
course yes here's a 50 year old with
hypercalcemia she had normal 25 normal P
th and she's fairly under mark please
but low normal PTH we laid proteins
undetectable but then 125 is really
quite high and so so let's think about
how we want to think about this so it's
where we might think about to explain
the differential diagnosis and so as
we're going to go into measuring other
hormonal levels like the igf-1 like
growth hormone and so in fact behind her
story is a pituitary tumor and so so
this is the case of unrecognized
acromegaly and which treatment would be
the transfer noodle adenoidectomy and
and then you can monitor afterwards and
in fact this case or when 25 did
normalize and she's doing well now
as you can imagine sometimes there are
incomplete reception again that would be
an indication for following the 125 in a
serial manner over time we're following
calcium overtime all right
okay v is another at women women with
high calcium her PTH is also low or
vitamin D is also normal range or
related protein is normal and then 125
is kind normal but not all rage ously
but she's got some visual field cuts how
we going approaches well again thinking
about what from the last case is igf-1
growth hormone our important level quite
follow-up tests again unrecognized
acromegaly
and in this case of MRI did show another
pituitary really neoplasm so again you
can treat that with transferred or
adenoidectomy so the calcium
[Music]
postoperatively is to remain look at
high the igf-1 is may high the growth
hormone down but still high then 1.5 is
still high okay so this isn't very
important clinical data then and
recognize that it was definitely an
incomplete reception with some therefore
then this is kind of consultation with
neurosurgical colleagues about next next
steps land for monitoring alright case
six
kidney stones we all see folks with
kidney stones and when we're most common
things will most severe causes of pain
so how my good cigar I should be helpful
here's kinda a nicely Grampa here's a
twenty four-year-old he said Kenny
stoned to that six years
he's got significant hypercalcemia
he's got hypercalcemia but he's got a
low PTH s would be expected that a
normal vitamin D and he's got a high 125
how even make sense with us let's go
through a differential diagnosis for the
hypercalcemia yes time okay we're going
to brought PTH row tfh world thing so is
this a case of malignancy is if they
over the past six years is there
something else going on into the case of
pituitary issues or even something else
going on so count about granulomatous
disease which are four sarcoid mentioned
TV and histo to cover a couple cases of
malignancies two particular cases
acromegaly what else might explain this
increase 125 and that is actually this
is a case of reduced functioning of the
24 a 1 and this can be due to
heterozygous or homozygous single
nucleotide polymorphisms or other
variations in the gene for sip 24 a 1
it's been reported in cases cases from
2014 but in January 2017 nice article by
carpenter really describing how that
there's actually a lot cases now reduced
function of 24 a 1 why is it so
important we see here that we talked
about the 125 being required to be
activated by through the 27 b1 from a 25
by notice of the breakdown products of
both 225 and the 125 have to go through
24 a 1 now if this is slow then these
levels will be high in particular well
countess than 125 being quite high if
this is quite slow so I imagine a few
years we might find that there are
certain medications which slow sip 24 a
1 certainly their medications like
dexamethasone which appear to speed up
24 a 1 it might also be right phantom as
well so these would be things that would
be of importance and concerning your
differential diagnosis here ok case 7 57
year old is that let's flank pain
anorexia 23 kilos of weight loss over
two months so yes you're thinking
malignancy malignancy malignancy catskin
chose a large left kidney mass with
retroperitoneal lymph node enlargement
okay it's a neoplasm malignancy get
biopsy is high-grade
clear renal cell carcinoma and you're
playing a surgical resection but let's
make sure that's not going to be
problems so you get some preoperative
evaluations where do you find well we've
got some nausea he's got a mild
hyponatremia is what sugar slightly high
any type of Kelsey mix with a low
albumin huh or are you going to take
this the next step
what's your at and what's your
assessment what's your plan so what two
different your diagnosis going through
this again okay going through the
sequence considering each of these steps
that we've talked about so pH is low 25
G it's normal they relate cocaine is
normal the 125 is high very
significantly
okay so trimming fluids let's take care
of do what we can to bring the calcium
down
I can ideally we'll get the will avoid
significant problems by monitoring and
rapidly and find that to code separately
is 125 is down to 24 with the calcium
being normalized for his albumin so in
pathology what's interesting here the
pathology showed a high-grade carcinoma
and so we can presume that resection of
this made a difference and the kind of
key taken point here is that there are
actually a lot of cases in the
literature of malignancy associated
hypercalcemia with a suppressed PTH and
a normal related protein so there's more
to the story here in creating 125 so
Samia is like huh okay so in the first
seven cases here we've talked about
hypercalcemia and the differential
diagnosis and many different ways it can
present and you can see where the 125 is
actually playing a very important role
in supporting your capacity to advocate
and both diagnose and treat your patient
now in case H is going to be a bit
different now we're going to change
things a bit now rickets as in the
picture here you think about being low
vitamin D stage we talked about people
don't get out of the Sun they don't have
any intake of vitamin D from a source in
this case is a 25 year old girl
disproportion growth she's got
perspiration constipation deformed
extremities walking difficulties partial
alopecia convulsions bone pain weak
muscles
she's got rickets but some like
something there's a lot more going on
it's
so of course we're going to get a 25
vitamin D level huh that's what we're
thinking but one else in exams got an
open fontanel for the forehead here at
her age it's a little bit unusual the
cranial sutures are normal
mild frontal bossing patchy dis piece of
hair widened distal metastasis of the
radius and ulna double joints sounding
like rickets rickets rickets
why didn't distal metaphysis with fibula
if she gets a letter X sign for well
this is briquette scoped proven
otherwise
when vitamin D is normal so what do we
do now well how's your calcium role is
really quite low in the case of
hypocalcemia and if they were capable
responsive hypocalcemia yes your PTH is
elevated so if the body is responding to
try to get to maintain normal calcium
levels or calcium homeostasis so you've
got a hypocalcemic bone problem at 25
year old or 25 month old girl so you
went look at the bones out Foss is quite
high and then 125 is quite high how do
we make sense of this well first thing
is if you're just going to say this you
know this kind of this is a case of
vitamin D resistant rickets and then
everything we see is a compensatory
reaction to that so we actually give
calcium intravenously because it's not
going to be it's not gonna be enough as
we absorbed through the intestinal
lining and we want to give activated
vitamin D and this and with this we can
see that the Alcott's levels normalize
the bone pain resolve strength has
increased her thyroid hormone is
normalized
so I'm going to case nine it just kind
of say oh yes in the unexpected cases of
hypocalcemia the 125 becomes important
guide to understanding the context and
for guiding you in your diagnosis and it
can guide you in your treatment you're
using 20 high dose Celtic trial in a
child or an adult that better consider
also sequentially testing the 125 levels
to make sure that you're not going
excessively high calcium will also be a
measure of that but they're giving
intravenous calcium so you may need more
of a complete picture for monitoring all
right case 9 I'm super osis you know
such a common issue and it's just so
surprising that the Surgeon General
women is not surprising that Surgeon
General I mean recently
you know stated that you know October
OSIS threatens every American and one of
the things that we can do in our own
optimizing our own health and minimize
our risk is make sure that we've got
good live in D levels of course that
there's no physical exam for that and so
measurement of vitamin D is so important
and obviously when something does have
osteoporosis and becomes even more
important to measure a vitamin D so this
is a 55 year old male so somebody
wouldn't necessarily expect to see
without your Perot psious unless there's
something else going on isn't it that
DEXA scan his T score is quite low it's
not it's not for join osteoporosis with
T score of minus 2.5 but minus 3.5 is we
have to know pretty significant
you've got ongoing fractures despite the
sauce to make treatment no fatigue
weakness weight loss Falls history of
chronic sinusitis there is more to this
picture this is not your run-of-the-mill
osteoporosis so how do we approach this
how doing that evaluate this bone
disease
well calcium of course we're going
caching that's normal
2500 M D that's normal okay PTH that's
normal
granting that's normals alphas is
elevated okay something's going on
phosphate is low okay that's a big clue
and then 125 is low so here we have a
case of significant bone disease with a
normal calcium but low phosphate and low
125 what's going on here
so hypophosphatemia is not reserved for
people who have been profoundly
malnourished it has a great deal to do
with other people as well so my
medication evaluated hypophosphatemia
you would expect to see an increase in
the 125 in this case we have a decrease
125 second point is that if you've got a
hypophosphatemia with low 125 there can
only really be one cause for this and
that is evan production of fgf 23 the
fiber next fibrinogen growth factor and
it will show you where that comes in
just a second here third thing is excess
production of fgf 23 is due to actually
a rare inherited condition or occult
tumors now because FTF 23 is only
recently been measurable there's
probably a lot more to the story but at
this case this time it's reasonable to
consider in the workup for
hypophosphatemia now what is it it's an
essential regulator phosphate
homeostasis and it has its own receptor
and a co-receptor and it inhibits
reabsorption of
state from the urine so therefore you're
spilling phosphate in the urine hyperox
Victoria and a relative hypophosphatemia
and because of the feedback loops is
going to decrease production of the 125
and therefore you're not going to have
activated vitamin D and so so
hypophosphatemia would be part of the
whole picture
no again here is the story notice that
fgf 23 is in the lower right hand corner
the 125 levels should up regulate it and
it in turn to down regulate production
of the 125 but in fact if it is
independently there are independently
excessive production or high levels of
this it will automatically down regulate
the production of 125 and notices at the
top of screen up regulate the breakdown
of vitamin D and so text youth and
someone would have low vitamin D levels
despite over-the-counter or even
prescription dosing of cholecalciferol
or forego Calcifer all so in this case
oh you get started
phosphate and calcitriol and go scanning
for tumors and home on behold this
chronic sinusitis issue is actually he's
got a malignancy causing this problem so
i go through section phosphate and the
125 normal on pain resolves ambulation
normalizes his death the scan goes to a
minus 3.5 to minus 1 point 7 so is
osteoporosis resolves it's completely
reversed
here's a citation for the case so what
do I want you to know we need to know
that 125 is the activated form of
vitamin D 25 is the 25 vitamin D is the
best measure for whole body status but
125 in best measure for the activation
we've got to measure 125 and
hypercalcemia evaluation and you need to
consider it an evaluation hypocalcemic
evaluations as we just showed the
hypophosphatemia would be reasonable as
well now differential diagnosis I'm kind
of can repeat repeat repeat but this is
we need to consider medicine cancer
osteo lytic lesions or myeloma
parathyroid is a collaborative related
protein from malignant C excessive
vitamin D excessive production again
malignancy or solid organ or lymphoma
prolonged immobilization could also
cause this as well an outpatient we
think about
hyperparathyroidism hyperthyroidism
diamond detoxification
paraneoplastic granuloma distances
legacies acromegaly and very rare others
now how is this use and lysis support
one one is diagnosis of the cause of
hyper or hypocalcemia 2 is monitoring of
calcitriol therapy and monitoring
calcitriol status with administration of
oral vitamin D as cholecalciferol or
Orgel caocao a frog in supplementation
where vitamin D appears to play a role
in regulation of so many key things the
body at sarcoid other granulomatous
disease so for example remember that TB
is
[Music]
is was actually treated for many years
by exposure to sunshine affective
vitamin D plays an incredibly important
role in macrophage activity and anti
vitamin D activity
well muscle kind of one uses as
measuring for people with kidney stone
issues this could be more important in
the future now there's one additional
clinical value we started out with
beginning we talked about the issue of
there being Ostia lytic lesions with
metastatic cancer causing a
hypercalcemia and then with point on
very important nuance evaluating people
with a history of cancer and this comes
from very interesting case study
presented in the BMJ and that is the one
with history of breast cancer presented
with widely diffused musculoskeletal
pain weakness fatigue variety of
symptoms with the suspicion of recurrent
breast cancer she had a bone scan and it
looks as you can see here it looks
pretty darn suspicious for for cancer
and so part of the whole whole thing is
that evaluation for her and with this
particular condition will vary around
the world as I understand it in the u.s.
we would do a biopsy of one of these
lesions to document whether it's cancer
in this case the patient was in the UK
and biopsies are not are not routinely
done so in this case they would be
really important then to that was a key
taking point is to get a measurement of
a 25 hydroxy D and a measure 125
dihydroxy D or maybe a parasite hormone
related protein we're looking at widely
metastatic cancer in this case this is
really important to know this patient
simply had vitamin D deficiency and and
had and there definitely this on this
bone scan the lesion found here were
strictly a matter of vitamin D
deficiency and simply replacing vitamin
D and a bone scan completely normalizes
so so I want to say thank you for your
attention thank you for your interest in
vitamin D and in the assessment of
hypercalcemia hypocalcemia and other
situations where or during the 125 can
be actually really helpful in your
clinical practice your capacity to serve
your patients what that being said we've
had a couple minutes for questions and
we'll open it up for questions right now
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get to the poor
we get started on the question and
answer session I would like to remind
our audience has the questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can okay so our first question today
let's just hop right on in doctor
poppycock can you explain when 25 hydro
hydro capacity vitamin B and 125 by
hydroxy vitamin B test should be ordered
I know you switch over okay all right so
so thank you for the question yes this
is such an important question and
there's a cop there so so key Tinkham
point here is that the 25 hydroxy test
is strictly for measurement of zooming I
never caught why am i coughing yeah
so excuse me the 25 hydroxy vitamin D is
great providing be status that should be
intense that there are we should be gang
on everyone in the population okay there
is a best measurement now the 125 though
is really limited to the cases are kind
of really sniveling unusual situations
that is the workup for hypercalcemia the
workup for hypo certain types of
hypocalcemia and in the cases we prevent
here included the workup for say unusual
case of osteoporosis hypophosphatemia
and like by far and away and about a
hundred to one physicians clinicians to
be ordering the 25 hydroxy and 1.5 is
really restricted to unusual situations
for which there are clear indications
rather than for everyday screening
purposes and thank you for this water
here so the second question
thank you for that the second question
asks what are the most common diagnoses
that are aided by abnormal 125 daya
hydroxy vitamin D level great well thank
you for this question and that's why I
really want to emphasize the
differential diagnosis for for
hypercalcemia and that's where we went
through with the hyperparathyroidism
hyperthyroidism we talked about
different types of malignancies the
parathyroid hormone-related protein they
talked about acromegaly detectable
granulomatous disease which includes
sarcoid histoplasmosis and the like and
and to be because I want you to pay
sensitive alchemy online I really like
to since you asked this question I
really would like you to kind of really
go back and review what the slides so if
the is going the great value in a
webinar like this is your supporting
your capacity to create a good
differential diagnosis and then be able
to think through the case but
hypercalcemia hypocalcemia and then we
made unusual things such as the after
grossest the kidney stones in life so I
say we're about at one hour right now is
another pressing question
yes we are an Isetta time so we'll do
one last question and then we'll go into
the clothes how do physicians Singlish
between rickets from hereditary rickets
well great question about rickets
rickets are really important to know
about because in fact actually we're
seeing more and more rickets with the
increased incidence and prevalence of
rickets is really due to 25 vitamin D
deficiency now it's interesting is you
recall rickets may have been Tiny Tim
and
quite Dickens and Scrooge rickets has
been we think about it kind of being in
the past to think about cities in which
there was no sunlight there's too much
smog overhead but in fact tips we though
we think about rickets as being time in
the past if that seemed more and more in
the present we live we work long hours
indoors we enjoy air conditioning we
move in the cities where there's so much
smog overhead that the ultraviolet B
rate B rays which are needed for
production of vitamin D with my contact
our skin just are not present so in fact
we're seeing acquired rickets in kind of
shockingly increasing numbers and need
to be part a differential diagnosis for
all children effect we need to also
consider that we don't want women going
through pregnancy vitamin D deficient so
ensuring a good vitamin D level minimum
of 20 nanograms per ml is going to be
really important and and nearly everyone
in this planet is at risk and here in
Minneapolis I'm forty five degrees north
and halfway to the North Pole and I can
only make vitamin D
between April 15th roughly and I think
Tax Day and Labor Day and it's about the
Sun between 10:00 and 3:00 and there's
no smog overhead and there's got a
shadow on the ground and I'm not wearing
sunscreen perfect I'm wearing clothing
I'm going to make some vitamin D but
anytime that my shadow is longer than I
am tall I cannot make vitamin D and
that's most a year in Minnesota so
that's what we need to worry about the
congenital vitamin rickets they've
talked about is really a dysfunction in
the whole a calcium homeostatic
regulatory system so we talked about in
one case here where there's disruption
in this and that's why it's really
important to not stop it saying oh this
patient has a normal vitamin D level
therefore it cannot be rickets we have
to take it to the next step we are
suspecting rickets and we all need to
suspecting rickets as pediatricians so
that would require getting the 125
dihydroxy vitamin D so knowledgeable
tests are really important that's why
I'm so glad you you stayed with this
webinar today I really wish you best
luck with your practice and they and
that I'm hoping they can find something
today that that will lead you to be able
to serve your patients well into the
future and I look forward to additional
questions you always reach me through my
website or through lab routes and so I
think you very much for your time and
attention today
take care
I would like to once again thank Gregory
plat macaque for his resignation any
closing do you have any final comments
any final comments well I think I've
said a lot today I'm really concerned I
wanna make sure that if you have any
questions or concerns you can contact me
through through the website the website
for my clinic or contact lab routes and
I look forward to being helpful so if I
can be helpful please let me go
thank you I would also like to thank our
sponsors via Sauron for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through November 2017 you will
receive an email from libraries alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we want you to Ford that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's presentation once
again thank you and we will see you next
time here at lab rude goodbye